j'ai demandé au préfet de
seine-saint-denis de faire fermer la
mosquée de pantin puisque son dirigeant
a relayé le message qui consiste
effectivement à dire que ce professeur
devait être intimidés et aujourd'hui 34
opération lancée de police elles ont
donné lieu à des judiciarisation pour
plusieurs d'entre elles
ans
[Musique]
nous fidèles de cette mosquée pourquoi
on paye pour l'erreur d'une personne
[Musique]
bise à bord ils ont manifestement le
cnca toi ils ont lancé une fatwa contre
ce professeur
manifestement produit aujourd'hui le
parquet antiterroriste verra s'il il les
qualifie comme complice d'actes
terroristes
[Musique]